oh
my God
[Music]
we have five minutes
hey guys come on here I'll for you
why
yeah
whatever
ready stop stop stop stop
hey
foreign
come on
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
break it right
I can get him
ready
the door don't open dude go go
stop right there put your hands up put
your hands up right now put your hands
up hands up turn around put your hands
up hands up hands up
don't reach what don't reach for it all
right
milk
there we go
sure wait let's do five
yeah
come on
470.
how much
so go get the car radio
so get the car man
you totally
late
yeah
thank you
as well
put the other two going to school
I dropped my cuff somewhere along I do
too
we put it in your car until uh stealth
gets here come on
foreign
[Applause]
everybody read to your rights
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can and will be used
against you in the coral allow you have
the right to attorney if you cannot
afford one
all right
now
foreign
[Music]
it's too hot out anyways
I'm gonna go look back there
my camera
I don't think so I think she has another
bag
do they all come in in different do they
all come in different cars yes these are
the ones
on Detroit the last couple days since
last week almost hitting people and just
grabbing cables this one and it was that
one yesterday
problem